economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar hablando
de la lenta recuperación que va a tener
américa latina según las proyecciones
del fondo monetario internacional hola
santiago buenas noches mire en la
reunión conjunta de primavera con el
banco mundial que inició este martes lo
primero que hizo el fondo monetario
internacional fue subir la proyección de
crecimiento mundial para este año ya no
cree que será del 5.5 sino del 6% sin
embargo cree que la recuperación en
américa latina' va a tener varias
velocidades dependiendo de si el país es
exportador por ejemplo o si depende del
turismo
la economía se ha beneficiado de medidas
políticas extraordinarias que han
aliviado las condiciones financieras y
han evitado una recesión económica más
profunda pero esas acciones pueden tener
consecuencias no deseadas las
vulnerabilidades financieras se han
intensificado
daniela de algo que no le gusta a los
ciudadanos y es el tema de impuestos si
está tomando fuerza la propuesta de
crear un impuesto mínimo global para las
empresas
me gustan los ciudadanos ni les gustan
las empresas tampoco en esta misma
reunión de la que hablábamos se dijo que
la propuesta que hizo el lunes eeuu y
que también ya varios años discutiéndose
sin éxito por ahora en la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico pues también va a ser
considerada escucharnos
we have for long bing durante mucho
tiempo hemos estado a favor de un
impuesto mínimo corporativo global
that we have you know es una gran
preocupación que tengamos una gran
cantidad de cambios de impuestos se
vació en países que envían dinero a
paraísos fiscales y eso está reduciendo
la base impositiva de la que los
gobiernos pueden recaudar ingresos y
hacer el gasto social y económico que se
requiere hablemos ahora daniela de
forbes que publicó este martes su famoso
ranking anual de los millonarios a nivel
internacional del complemento el dato no
estamos en esa lista usted yo no ni lo
estaremos en mucho tiempo pues desde
reporte santiago destaca la explosión de
personas con un patrimonio superior
superior a mil millones de dólares ya
casi pese al impacto de la pandemia
estos son más de dos mil setecientos
esos amigos un 30 por ciento más que el
año pasado y equivale a que hubo un
multimillonario más cada 17 horas
sorpréndase entre estos recién llegados
está por ejemplo
wolf quien es la presidenta de bombay
que es
a la aplicación de citas que salió a
bolsa este año ahora en cuanto a la
fortuna a santiago
el aumento fue incluso superior del 64
por ciento entre todos amasan alrededor
de 13 billones de dólares vamos ahora a
santiago con la lista de los más ricos
que está encabezada por segundo año
consecutivo por el fundador de amazon
jeff bezos quien a propósito respalda el
aumento de impuestos propuesto por joe
bites le sigue y lan más que el dueño de
tesla quien saltó desde el puesto 31
hasta el segundo y el francés bernard al
norte quien es el presidente de louis
vuitton y cierra de los 3 con 150 mil
millones de dólares siempre en medio de
la crisis de la pandemia hubo también
oportunidades para muchos hablemos de la
isla de groenlandia que pertenece al
reino de dinamarca y allí van a celebrar
elecciones que son decisivas para la
economía de ese territorio autónomo
santiago el componente económico de los
comicios en este territorio autónomo
danés tiene que ver con que el resultado
depende de que se autorice o no el
desarrollo de una mina de tierras raras
de las tierras raras se extraen
minerales clave para la fabricación de
productos de alta tecnología que van
desde celulares hasta vehículos
eléctricos pues el partido
social-demócrata apoya este proyecto
pero los sondeos apuntan al triunfo del
partido opositor socialista que se opone
a él lo curioso santiago es que estas
minas las quiere explotar una empresa
australiana con capital chino a pesar de
que hay muchas diferencias entre estos
dos países esta podría ser una
estrategia sin embargo para que china
consolide su monopolio sobre la
extracción de estos minerales lo cierto
es que esta isla de 2 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados y un poco más de 50
mil habitantes es muy atractiva por sus
recursos naturales pues de ahí viene que
el presidente el expresidente donald
trump planteará la posibilidad de
comprarla en 2019 claro que decir muchos
recursos hablemos ahora de los
indicadores como los fue las principales
bolsas o street es el niño de rojo
después de varios días en récord en
europa por su parte se restableció la
operación normal de las bolsas después
de semanas alta con alzas en sus
principales índices y en américa latina
hubo sí
mixtos con un aumento significativo en
buenos aires- cifra del día para la
tierra 4.000 millones de euros con los
que va a ser recapitalizada la aerolínea
air france
muchas gracias daniela por esta
actualización del mundo económico es
todo por el momento aquí en france24
siga con nosotros
[Música]